it's not the first time that classified
documents either ours or from our allies
have ended up in uh as bizarre as it
sounds and sort of The Gaming Community
yeah right and maybe there's I don't
know maybe there's some connection that
we can figure out between uh people who
spend a lot of time in in the gaming
world and you know individuals who have
access to classified.com
in front of screens all day yeah yeah so
and and you know it's again
you can't because of the need to share
information right and there is a
legitimate need to do that you just have
to be careful about how you do it you
don't want to again you don't want to
make such a large playing field that you
have no control over what the hell
you're doing but because of that and
because it's just a human endeavor
you're always gonna have the potential
for a problem like this but if you don't
have consequences for it then you're
you're increasing the likelihood that it
could happen again